georges17 historique national et le lieu
de reprise allemande une centaine
l'acadien avant leur déportation
c'est cette partie de l'histoire qui ont
fait un lieu d'importance pour les
acadiens
on connaît les conditions de détention
des acadiens sur cette île
il y avait il y avait aucun abri et veut
pas de rations il était livré aux
éléments certains sont morts de froid de
faim
ce triste chapitre de l'histoire qui
fait en sorte que plusieurs acadiens
aimerait bien se rendre sur l'île pour
se recueillir
mais impossible de s'y rendre son
autorisation exceptionnelle de parcs
canada
cela changera l'été prochain avec un
financement d'ottawa de deux millions de
dollars pour la construction d'un quai
sur l'île et 1 million 600 mille dollars
pour financer l'encadrement des visites
car l'histoire fait en sorte que les
l'intérêt souci les micmacs qui
fréquentait le lieu bien avant que les
anglais ils construisent une base navale
les visites de lille pourrait donc
intéresser beaucoup de gens on veut pas
que ça devienne carnaval derrière on
veut quand même qui est certain respect
que ce soit quand même fait de façon
respectueuse les visites sur l'île
la fédération acadienne espère
travailler avec parcs canada afin
d'élaborer les visites sur place
parcs canada est ouvert à lille on
compte travailler de près avec les
acadiens les micmacs afin de concevoir
l'expérience des visiteurs sur cette île
affirmé erik nielsen responsable de
l'uip aux parcs canada
les visites de lille georges devrait
commencer lors de la prochaine saison
touristique ici parlent déjà
radio-canada halifax